hallo leute herzlich willkommen zurück
bei kali antwortet ich beantworte heute
wieder kommentare und fragen zusammen
frage 1 4100 1986 1 schreibt hallo ich
habe eine sehr wichtige frage wo ist mir
jetzt freue ich mich auf deswegen rufe
ich sie jetzt einfach mal an weil
ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich habe mir
schon seit monaten nicht erreicht war ja
dann ist diese freie plätze leider
unbeantwortet
nächste frage kommt von maria abdul
barkey sie schreibt vielen dank für
deine videos kari ich lerne jetzt
deutsch in saudi arabien
ich liebe deutsch aber ich habe keine
deutschen freunde hier leider ich
benutze leider benutze ich die sprache
nicht
was kann ich tun um fluent also fließend
zu sprechen
danke sehr für deine hilfe davaria ich
finde es cool dass du in saudi arabien
deutsch lernst und diese frage die du
stellst die hatten wir ja schon mal
gestellt bekommen und auch schon
beantwortet generell ist natürlich
schwierig wenn keine deutschen freunde
es ist das schade aber es gibt natürlich
verschiedene wege um die sprache besser
zu lernen erst einmal diese türme gucken
ist schon mal nicht schlecht aber
natürlich noch mehr deutsch gucken und
noch mehr kontakt bekommen mit der
sprache ist auf jeden fall hilfreich und
das kannst du zum beispiel machen indem
du ja deutsche filme guckt mit
untertiteln deutsches radio es gibt zum
beispiel auch deutsche nachrichten lang
gesprochen deutsche sachen lesen und
ganz wichtig ist dass du dir auch
konversationen vorstellst also
tatsächlich dialoge im kopf hast als ich
damals französisch gelernt habe habe ich
immer in meinem kopf versucht auf
französisch zu denken verschiedene
situationen durchzugehen in
verschiedenen situationen mir sätze
auszudenken und das hat damals ganz gut
funktioniert was wir ja auch noch machen
ein letzter tipp ist wir machen diese
basic racers und in diesen zehn setzen
versuchen wir immer viele redewendungen
oder ausdrücke unterzubringen
es ist ganz wichtig wenn du nicht im
direkten kontakt mit einer sprache bist
dass du irgendwie raus bekommst wie die
leute tatsächlich sprechen wie sie es
längst sprechen wie sie verschiedene
ausdrücke die frische sachen ausdrücken
und dafür haben wir diese zehn sätze
gemacht davon sieht seht ihr
mittlerweile schon 20 online und es
kommen noch viele mehr
laut townsend sagt ich habe eine frage
für euch warum verwenden die deutschen
so oft englische worte es ärgert mich
dass ich deutsch lernen und meine eigene
sprache fast mehr hörer als deutsch was
ist die meinung des volkes ja leuten
cent also die meinung des volkes kann
ich natürlich auch dir schlecht sagen ja
ich würde mal sagen generell ist erstmal
ist es nicht so dass du hast mir
englisch als deutsch 99 prozent aller
worte in der deutschen sprache sind
immer noch deutsch
zweitens ist eine sprache lebendig und
das soll sie auch sein wir reden ja auch
nicht mehr deutsch wie wir im
mittelalter deutsch gesprochen haben
oder wie im 18 jahrhundert das deutsch
ist auch anders als heute und es ändert
sich das andere sprachen andere sprachen
beeinflussen ist aber ganz normal du
hast ja in unserem listen schon gesehen
dass wir zum beispiel im deutschen auch
wörter haben aus dem französischen aus
dem lateinischen sogar noch latein wird
seit 1000 jahren nicht mehr gesprochen
und immer noch gibt es worte weiter
davon
und so ist es ganz natürlich dass wir
auch englischen worte haben denn die
englische kultur vor allem die
amerikanische die britische die hat sehr
viel produktives zustande
8 und ist auch sehr dominant in
bestimmten bereichen in der welt ob das
jetzt wissenschaft ist publikation
literatur politik und natürlich ist es
ganz normal dass wir bestimmte worte
übernehmen ich persönlich finde das
nicht schlecht es gibt natürlich ein
paar menschen die es ein bisschen
übertreiben ehrlich gesagt und dann kann
man auch witze drüber machen und das
kann man auch kritisieren das ist völlig
legitim
trotzdem sollte man sich nicht über
jedes ismus aufregen
kleiner tipp für dich noch es gibt sogar
im deutschen so etwas wie shine angeht
ist das heißt das in worte die englisch
klingen und englisch ausgesprochen
werden aber gar nicht aus dem englischen
kommen ist das mich also das fanden wir
ziemlich gut und deswegen gibt es dazu
demnächst auch eine eigene episode
darüber sei gespannt die metro schreibt
ihr seid einfach nur ein links grünes
neoliberales dummes pack wenn der
bürgerkrieg in europa deutschland
beginnt von der sed vorausgesagt im
jahre 2020 werdet ihr endlich aufwachen
hohen kosten hernandez hoffentlich
richtig ausgesprochen schreibt bitte
eine folge über was denken die deutschen
über spanien spanisch also spanier oder
spanien dankeschön
diese fragen wird schon ganz oft
gestellt bekommen viele spanier lärm ihr
deutsch und arbeiten auch in deutschland
deswegen ist das mit sicherheit für euch
interessant aber es gibt über spanien
also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher wir
können das natürlich mal ausprobieren
aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass
die menschen auf der strasse nicht
besonders viel sagen werden weil mit
spanien verbinden wir weder positives
noch negatives wir haben keine bestimmte
meinung über spanien und das einzige was
wir verbinden ist eigentlich positiv
spanien ist ein populäres urlaubsland
für deutsche deutsche fahren gerne nach
den siegen von spanien oder auf die
spanischen inseln wie mallorca und ich
glaube das ist auch schon alles für
hätten sangria sangria sagen vielleicht
die man sangria party am strand
aber natürlich weiß ich was du meinst
und was interessant findest ich würde
natürlich auch gerne wissen was denken
spanier über deutschland schreibt du mir
das doch mal ja zu unserer letzten
episode zum thema arbeit will haben wir
euch gefragt was wie definiert ihr denn
arbeit schreibt errors 39 viel arbeit
gleich viel geld gleich schöne frauen
ganz einfach
ja was soll man dazu noch sagen du hast
es raus ja wir sollten sie sollten so
ein preis machen so ein für die beste
für die frage der woche sie kriegt
sensor zum ehren award so die frage der
woche die antwort einfach der kommentar
der woche kommt von eros 39 er sagt viel
arbeit gleich viel geld gleich ihre
frauen die letzte frage
letzte frage für heute kommt von paul
metz hallo kali ich habe für dich eine
frage was sind die unterschiede was ist
der unterschied zwischen den wörtern nur
eben und halt ich höre diese worte immer
wieder in den gleichen kontext und würde
gerne wissen ob man alle drei gleich
benutzen kann
japan also grundsätzlich sind diese drei
worte komplett verschieden
alle drei haben eine eigene bedeutung
und eben hat sogar ganz viele bedeutung
geben kann zum beispiel heißen auf
englisch even just flat zb der tisch ist
eben
ich bin eben nach hause gekommen das
kann sogar heißen ex erklären wie man
sagte mir du bist dumm ich sage eben
genau das was ein gutes beispiel halt
hingegen heißt eigentlich so was wie
stopp auf deutsch oder holt gold an und
nur heißt just oli also drei völlig
unterschiedliche worte aber du hast
recht wenn du sagst du hast diese sachen
schon mal in einem ähnlichen kontext
gehört jetzt fragt sich natürlich wie
kann das sein
diese drei worte werden auch als modell
partikel benutzt modal partikel sind
etwas kompliziert denn das sind worte
die haben eigentlich eine bedeutung
werden aber manchmal in einem satz
benutzt ohne dass sie diese bedeutung
die eigentliche bedeutung haben sondern
dann haben sie eine andere bedeutung
modal partikel sind worte die ein ersatz
aussage einen bestimmten ton eine
bestimmte einstellung eine bestimmte
meinung geben und so werden diese drei
worte auch benutzt und zumindest eben
und halt sind in diesem kontext in
manchmal identisch ein beispiel dazu ich
mich fragt jemand zum beispiel warum ist
die tomate roth ich will sagen das ist
so was sage ich im deutschen kann ich
das besser sagen in dem ich einen modal
partikel als bestätigung ein gebe weil
was soll ich ich muss das ja irgendwie
betonen das ist so ich sage das ist halt
so das ist eben so
das ist einfach so damit betone ich
wirklich dass es keine andere
möglichkeit gibt und dafür benutzt man
solche modelle partikeln in diesem
zusammenhang sind also eben und halt
identisch und kann ausgetauscht werden
ja liebe leute das war schon für diese
woche etwas kürzer diese woche wir haben
uns sehr gefreut über eure fragen wir
hoffen ihr schickt uns noch mehr und
vielleicht kriegen wir nächste woche
noch so tolle fragen und vielleicht
sogar noch mehr wir freuen uns darauf
weinfest zuschauern dank an alle die uns
unterstützen
bei kathrin durch eure tollen e mails
durch das feedback freuen uns auf eure
unterstützung
danke fürs zuschauen und bis nächste
woche